hey guys it's Charlie so today we're
going to be talking about behind the
scenes Marvel drama in the movie
universe pre Captain America Civil War
you'll barely believe it but there was
actually things that happen behind the
scenes that almost cost us not only
Spider Man but Robert Downey jr. in the
movie itself it was crazy
and this is mostly intended to be like a
funny disaster averted story like wipe
your forehead we almost got hit by a
giant semi-truck so they'd been working
on the movie but there were all kinds of
things going on that eventually led to
Marvel Studios breaking away from Marvel
proper and going off to what people
started to call Feige island as it you
know like this self-contained
environment where Feige is king and they
can make all the crazy weird awesome
movies that they want to make reporting
to alan horne who's the chair of disney
pictures you know the parent company of
Marvel instead of Marvel boss Ike
Perlmutter this doesn't have to end in a
fight Tony
you just started a war so the real drama
that was you know kind of threatening to
tear all these movies apart in the
reasons for a lot of weird decisions and
things that you may not have liked in
Marvel movies that watered them down all
come down to the idea that eccentric
billionaires and lawyers ruin everything
or almost ruin everything
because this all culminated towards the
end of the summer 2015
obviously Captain America came out it
was great Marvel Studios went off on its
own but what the hell is the drama
why is everybody fighting well you know
first off there's always going to be a
lot of disagreement when you're making
movies that cost more than a hundred
million dollars even movies that are
cheaper than that in the final reported
budget for Captain America Civil War was
two hundred and fifty million dollars
but obviously it didn't start out that
big it didn't get that big until they
finally decided to put all those
Avengers characters in it and blow it up
into this big Avengers 2.5 movie but the
Marvel civil war going on behind the
scenes as they were making this movie so
early on they knew they were going to
make a third Captain America movie
Feige had a number of ideas depending on
stuff that worked out you know would
have been awesome to get spider-man in
it but if we can't get him we have this
black panther character that we're going
to introduce will expand his role so the
other early point of contention was
Robert Downey jr. who as many people
know now comes with this huge price tag
and here's where you get eccentric
billionaires trying to ruin things
so obviously the movies make billions of
dollars but you're not going to get Iron
Man 2 reciting other contract appear in
more movies unless you can meet his
price he just has a slightly different
bargaining power than the other actors
that aren't in quite as favorable a
position but not to throw Robert Downey
jr. under the bus he's actually a really
awesome person and he goes to bat for
his other actors to try and get them
more money for their movies so in a
real-world sense he's sort of like the
Iron Man leading the Avengers team that
is the actors that are making the
Avengers movies but the villain on the
other side of this story is Ike
Perlmutter will call Captain America
Kevin Feige like the guy who's trying to
do the right thing make amazing movies
but you have the businesspeople at the
top that really just care about money in
toys it really gets back to toys the
reason why Perlmutter is so against
spending money and this actually goes
back all the way to phase one which I'll
explain in a second is because he's a
toy man he came into ownership of Marvel
with a V Arad through his toy business
so you know largely Marvel was useful to
him as a toy company nothing to do with
the comics very little to do with the
movies the movies to him or more of like
an advertisement for the toys they sell
like you make a billion dollars on a
movie but you make four or five billion
dollars on the toys that you sell in the
merchandising so you have Kevin Feige
you know mr. Captain America on the
other side who cares about the movie
wants to make this amazing motion
picture but then you have the toy man on
the other side that really just wants to
sell a lot of toys so even though this
kind of like internal Marvel Civil War
came to a head during the making of
Captain America Civil War you've been
going on for a long time like the reason
you haven't seen a black widow movie is
because Perlmutter felt like they
couldn't sell toys based on a black
widow movie so it's all about the toy
business it's all about the suits
eccentric billionaires at the top
they're the ones that are ruining
everything and if you think that sounds
bad it gets worse reportedly early on in
the development of civil war when they
were negotiating with Sony for the use
of the spider-man character bringing him
home home coming into the Marvel
Universe reportedly Ike Perlmutter was
making that very very difficult he was
sticking on the money part of the deal
so you have to imagine like even though
they haven't disclosed the terms of the
sharing arrangement of the spider-man
character you have to imagine that
Sony's like will make all the money but
you'll get all the credit people will
love Marvel that much more as a brand
and we'll trust you we'll go see your
other movies you'll make all the money
on those movies so we'll never actually
know what the financial arrangement is
you know in terms of licensing and toys
and all this stuff with Marvel and Sony
but you have to imagine that the toy man
at the top wanted to make more money off
the spider-man character
then Sony was willing to give and it
almost killed the deal so whatever they
did in the room to get him to quiet down
they were able to make that deal and get
the spider-man character so wipe your
forehead in relief disaster averted so
what changes a result of that obviously
the people at Disney which bought out
Marvel want them to make good movies
like they care about that people like
the movies they'll buy the other stuff
so they're not quite as worried about
say like using a character that they
feel like won't sell toys they're okay
with Kevin Feige making really weird
movies things that look different that
our cookie cutter that aren't basically
like to our ads for toys which is Doctor
Strange which is Thor Ragnarok that's
why they look so different like if
you've seen Doctor Strange you
understand like how it doesn't look like
any other Marvel movie that's come
before but if they had still been under
Ike Perlmutter's control in Marvel
proper like before they spun off they
wouldn't have been able to make the
movie that way it would have looked
exactly like the first Iron Man movie he
would have been super boring it would
have become the thing that people have
said that Marvel films were turning into
these cookie cutter movies that they
make on an assembly line that all looked
the same so obviously a lot of us
haven't seen all these new movies yet
because they're making them right now
like Doctor Strange is just the latest
example of a really big push into a
different type of storytelling that
they've done before visually creatively
just all around very different from what
you've seen before Thor Ragnarok Kevin
Feige has said is so different from the
previous Thor films that he's not even
considering it a sequel he's considering
it like the first in a totally different
line of Thor movies some of the best
examples of that is the way they went
with the 80s logos for the movies at
Comic Con they released those at
comic-con but those are going to be the
logos for the movies in that funny Thor
video they probably wouldn't been able
to do that under the old Marvel system
but Kevin Feige moved off created Feige
Island with the help of Alan horn at
Disney and they're off doing their own
thing making all kinds of movie magic
you'll recognize that in the DC Universe
there's the era of geoff johns that
we're getting into they're slowly
starting to do that same thing to where
like the businesspeople the suits the
eccentric billionaires aren't ruining
things quite as much or at least don't
have as much direct access to do it so a
lot of you have asked for Marvel Comics
videos like this you know like
behind-the-scenes drama stories
explained you know people being crazy
one of the best examples of Marvel
Comics periods that was just rife with
all kinds of behind-the-scenes drama
where the Jim shooter years comic book
people will recognize this but I'll
totally do a video about you know behind
the scenes WTF drop just like crazy
stuff that would happen that you would
think would be fictitious it's so
ridiculous but it's actually true it all
happened so just let me know in the
comments like if you want to suggest
like a behind the scenes you know WTF
drama video just write it below in the
comments I'll try to do like at least
one a week or something like that just
depending on what comes along but I'll
do movies and comic book stuff this was
more of a movie video like you think
that Marvel is actually doing really
well but behind the scenes they have as
many problems as anybody else at any
other movie studio it's just that you
don't hear about it as much but I think
it's absolutely fascinating when you
hear stories like this like you go see
the movies and you're like okay you know
this is great I really like these
characters but then you learn about all
this stuff happening behind the curtain
you're just like oh wow this is crazy
so feel free to suggest DC and Marvel
videos you know both comics and movie
stuff there's just so many stories about
crazy stuff especially comics I feel
like there are more stories about the
comic book stuff happening behind the
scenes at Marvel and DC just because
we've only really had these movie
studios making these movies for maybe
like the last 20 30 years and there's
been twice as much time spent with comic
book stuff forget hype and for those of
you that are asking just enough people
seem to like really want me to bring
back arrow episode videos so those
probably will come back but I'll be
doing DC stuff this weekend too so I'll
remind everyone when I post my next DC
video but I will post a non-spoilery
Doctor Strange review this weekend
probably Saturday morning so be sure and
go see it when you get the chance
because it's awesome for a number of
different reasons no spoilers please do
not post Doctor Strange spoilers in the
comments
everybody wipe your forehead disaster
averted none of those shenanigans should
be happening any more now that Kevin
Feige is off with Marvel
Studios on their own but why you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click down here for that Thor behind the
scenes video from yesterday and you can
click here for the Ghost Rider origin
story trailer in all the Johnny Blaze
Easter eggs from this week's agent of
shield thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight there are two types of
beings in the universe